messieurs dames bonjour donc je vous
salue individuellement madame Berchère
messieurs Combet Ibanez monsieur le
rapporteur nous reprenons donc
aujourd'hui nos travaux de la commission
d'enquête en recevant trois auteurs d'un
projet de proposition de loi visant à
diminuer la consommation d'énergie pour
le bâti que vous avez adressé en juillet
dernier aux député de la nupesse madame
vous avez été maire de Bouguenais dans
la Loire-Atlantique vous avez combattu
le projet d'aéroport de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes et vous avez
également été membre d'anticorps une
association de lutte contre la
corruption monsieur Combes vous êtes
économiste spécialisé sur les sujets de
politique climatique membres d'attaques
et co-auteur de plusieurs essais sur la
crise climatique et environnementale
enfin Monsieur libanaise vous êtes
économiste et consultant cofondateur des
rencontres annuelles des lanceurs
d'alerte
nous vous recevons car vous avez tous
les trois je l'ai dit au début de mes
propos adressés en juillet 2022 une
lettre ouverte au parlementaire de la
nupesse accompagnée d'une proposition de
loi visant à engager une politique de
rénovation énergétique du bâtiment privé
français sans reste à charge pour les
propriétaires la contrepartie de ce
financement est une obligation pour les
propriétaires de logement et de
bâtiments tertiaires à usage de bureau
d'entreprendre des travaux d'isolation
et de modifications de mode de chauffage
quand les conditions l'exigent et le
permettent ces travaux seraient pris en
charge via un fond se finançant grâce à
une inscription des financements en
faveur d'une isolation ou d'un
changement de mode de chauffage sur le
registre des hypothèques
madame messieurs avec cette proposition
vous soulevez une question majeure de
l'accélération de la rénovation
énergétique le zéro reste à charge les
chiffres le prouvent pour nombre de
ménages c'est leur situation financière
face au coût estimé des travaux qu'ils
soient d'ailleurs partiel ou globaux qui
les incite très souvent à repousser
voire à ne pas faire de rénovation de
leur logement supprimer ce frein du
reste à charge est une intention louable
mais difficile à mettre en oeuvre vous
nous expliquerons vous expliquerez
comment vous pensez pouvoir y parvenir
sur quel modèle de financement repose ce
dispositif vous indiquez soutenir la
création d'un fond qui financerait ses
opérations de rénovation en payant les
opérateurs et les entreprises en charge
de travaux grâce à une inscription sur
le registre des hypothèques comme
garantie pouvez-vous nous expliquer en
détail le fonctionnement de ce fond
enfin je souhaiterais obtenir votre avis
sur les politiques gouvernementales
actuelles d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique l'absence de reste à charge
0 est-elle pour vous la seule cause de
l'échec d'atteinte des objectifs de
rénovation des logements
quels sont les autres dysfonctionnements
que vous identifiez et quel serait les
alternatives à mettre en place pour y
remédier avant de vous laisser la parole
pour répondre à ses premières questions
et pour un propos introductif que je
vous propose d'une quinzaine de minutes
que vous vous répartirez comme vous
l'entendez donc il me reviennent de vous
indiquer que cette audition elle est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles 4 34-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
donc d'une façon formelle je vous
demande donc je vous invite à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité a levé la main droite et à
dire je le jure
je vous en remercie je vous laisse
maintenant la parole après votre
intervention monsieur de rapporteur bien
sûr ne manquera pas de vous poser un
certain nombre de questions
complémentaires à celle que j'ai déjà
posée mais aussi au vu de l'exposé que
vous allez nous faire donc je vous
laisse la parole Madame Monsieur Merci
merci madame messieurs
vous avez rappelé notre proposition je
tiens d'abord en préalable à préciser
que nous avons écrit à de nombreux
parlementaires de sensibilité différente
et nous avons aussi transmis à madame la
Première ministre le dossier de notre
proposition elle l'a elle-même transmis
au ministre en charge Monsieur Olivier
Klein donc notre proposition est
adressée à vraiment à l'ensemble de tous
les gens de tous les décideurs car nous
pensons que le sujet ne se prête pas
d'éventuelles controverses politiques
mais à une vraie prise en charge de la
question voilà je voulais puisque vous
nous avez déjà présenté rapidement dire
que notre configuration d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes trois avec des parcours
différents mais nous nous sommes
retrouvés sur cette question
fondamentale parce qu'en fait nous avons
constaté la difficulté à passer à une
échelle importante et pertinente or
il y a des dispositifs depuis de
nombreuses années et nous pensons que
c'est peut-être l'angle par lequel nous
avons jusqu'à présent regardé les
questions de rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments qui font que nous ne sommes
pas à la hauteur des enjeux c'est
pourquoi la proposition que nous avons
faite est effectivement
peut-être un peu étonnante ou différente
de ce qui existe jusque là puisque on le
verra au cours de la présentation jusque
là on propose des financements
extrêmement compliqués avec des cases
avec des des conditions d'accès et
finalement nous n'avons pas l'efficacité
peut-être attendu alors on va essayer de
faire une présentation assez rapide
de notre proposition alors il faut que
je manipule ceci non ça n'est pas ça qui
fait avancer voilà
passons rapidement parce que je pense
que vous savez tous tout cela la
mauvaise isolation des bâtiments à des
conséquences directes sur la
consommation énergétique en hiver et
aussi en été et probablement de plus en
plus souvent en été une émission accrue
de CO2 la dégradation de la santé par la
pollution liée aux particules fines
émises une baisse du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et une augmentation des charges
des entreprises à cause de cette
consommation d'énergie et évidemment en
corollaire une fragilisation de
l'indépendance énergétique du pays
alors la part du chauffage
dans le dans le bâtiment est important
puisque le secteur du bâtiment
représente 44% de l'énergie consommée en
France loin devant le secteur des
transports
chaque année le secteur du bâtiment émet
plus de 123 millions de tonnes de CO2 et
c'est évidemment un des domaines clés
dans la lutte contre le réchauffement
climatique pour rendre le bâtiment plus
économe il faut rénover massivement
l'existant et développer des normes plus
strictes pour les bâtiments neufs mais
ce n'est pas notre propos nous nous
sommes vraiment sur la question de la
rénovation de l'existant
donc l'isolation c'est pour nous le
premier impératif et nous en voulons
pour preuve des textes tout à fait
sérieux et officiels puisque nous avons
retrouvé les textes de l'ADEME en 2021
la première étape doit viser les travaux
d'isolation et de ventilation pour
éviter les pathologies et un
surdimensionnement des systèmes de
production de chauffage en effet changer
de système de chauffage peut être
intéressant mais encore faut-il que les
bâtiments soient isolés correctement
nous avons aussi retrouvé donc
un article de l'OCDE l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui dit
aussi en anglais cette fois qu'il y a
effectivement une priorité dans la
l'isolation des bâtiments et enfin dans
le comité d'évaluation du plan France
relance le rapport 2022 donc tout à fait
récent un système de chauffage ne peut
être performant sans isolation adéquate
l'isolation étant un prérequis dans un
parcours de rénovation cohérent et
optimisé donc effectivement
l'isolation est pour nous le point
numéro 1
avant même la recherche de sources
d'énergie pour chauffer alors le
fonctionnement actuel que nous avons
regardé dont un certain nombre d'entre
nous ont pu bénéficier ou pas d'ailleurs
parce que c'est assez compliqué ma prime
rénove qui s'est substituée à beaucoup
d'autres dispositifs précédents prévoit
une aide à la rénovation énergétique
calculer en fonction des revenus du
démon du demandeur c'est donc un des
points importants qui aboutit à ces
tableaux extrêmement compliqués que vous
connaissez tous avec le nombre de
personnes dans le ménage les revenus etc
en fonction des travaux retenus un
contrôle des dossiers de demande de
prime au total un dossier qui reste
complexe à monter au point qu'on voit
même la création de de cabinet pour vous
aider à monter un dossier ce qui est
tout de même peut-être un peu compliqué
et la loi actuelle ne prévoit pas
d'obligation d'isoler mais elle prévoit
une interdiction à venir de louer des
biens très mal isolés donc
la contrainte intervient non pas sur
l'obligation d'isoler aujourd'hui mais
sur l'interdiction de louer des biens
qui seraient très mal isolés qui
seraient dans la dans les dernières
catégories que vous connaissez sur le
diagnostic alors ces conséquences les
conséquences du système actuel les
propriétaires à qui l'on donne de
l'argent puisque ce sont des subventions
ont un reste à charge important
donc il y a un problème là et réel pour
ceux qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'assumer le reste à charge lorsqu'ils
sont bailleurs ils augmentent souvent
les loyers selon le principe assez
évident du retour sur investissement si
j'ai été obligé de mettre de l'argent
j'essaye de le récupérer sur le sur la
location pour l'isolation des seuls
logements il faudrait un budget de
subvention
d'au moins 300 milliards d'euros de
subventions c'est-à-dire d'argent à
donner d'argent public à donner les
propriétaires devant financer le solde
ce qui freine évidemment la décision
d'investir
les bâtiments à usage commercial ou
tertiaires ne sont pas intégrés
dans le dispositif actuel qui concerne
les logements or les bâtiments
commerciaux et tertiaires sont aussi des
gouffres énergétiques et il faut s'en
occuper comme pour le reste donc il y a
en gros 25 millions de bâtiments
dont 30 millions de logements à rénover
le budget nécessaire à l'isolation de
tous ces bâtiments se montrent à une
somme qui paraît astronomique comme ça
1000 milliards d'euros on a pris un
chiffre moyen 40000 euros ce qui n'est
évidemment pas le cas pour tous les
logements ou pour tous les bâtiments
oui oui par bâtiment par bâtiment parce
que précisément il y a des logements
dans les bâtiments dans les 25 millions
de bâtiments il y a les logements mais
par exemple un bâtiment de copropriété
c'est des centaines ou des dizaines de
logements donc effectivement la
différence entre 25 millions de
bâtiments et 30 millions de logements
c'est les logements collectifs
ce qui fait tout de même au total
300 à 500 milliards de subventions
puisque aujourd'hui on est dans un
système de subvention
donc 300 à 500 milliards donnés par la
puissance publique et de l'autre côté
500 à 700 milliards de financement de la
part des propriétaires évidemment
l'enjeu est colossal donc il nous paraît
que le système de la subvention n'est
actuel n'est pas forcément adaptée à
l'enjeu de rénovation massive
qu'il faudrait mettre en place pour dire
voilà
peut-être juste un élément en fait les
25 millions de bâtiments que nous avons
mis et les 30 millions de logements il y
a en France 37 millions de logements
donc on est parti sur des logements
ayant besoin d'être rénovés c'est pour
ça qu'on est au chiffre de 30 millions
et il y a 30 millions de bâtiments et on
a réduit à 25 millions de bâtiments
parce qu'on a considéré que c'était la
le nombre de bâtiments à rénover
mesdames et messieurs bonjour à toutes
et à tous
ce qu'on vous propose donc c'est un
système un petit peu orthogonal elle
aussi ça m'existant puisque c'est
d'arrêter avec ce dispositif de la
subvention aux propriétaires
également pour comprendre notre
proposition il faut bien se rendre
compte qu'on est là sur une intervention
sur du bâti sur
des immeubles et que donc du coup ça
donne possibilité d'utiliser des
dispositifs économiques spécifiques
d'intervention qui nous permettent
d'éviter justement le régime de la
subvention en bien des points
critiquables je veux juste ajouter un
élément sur ma prime rénov aujourd'hui
on a simplement 21% des primes rénov qui
sont dédiées à l'isolation l'essentiel
va ailleurs et simplement 6% de ses
primes qui vont à la rénovation globale
des bâtiments donc en fait on laisse de
côté l'essentiel de l'enjeu que sans la
rénovation de ces passwords thermiques
la rénovation globale de l'ensemble des
bâtiments notre proposition elle repose
sur trois principes le premier c'est de
considérer que
les pouvoirs publics mettent à
disposition la totalité du montant des
travaux
pour l'ensemble des rénovations de
l'ensemble des propriétaires sans aucune
condition de ressources
ceci va avec nécessairement une
obligation de rénovation pour les
propriétaires ou à rebours l'obligation
que nous proposons d'imposer sur les
propriétaires va avec le fait que les
pouvoirs publics s'engagent donc à
financer sans condition de ressources et
donc sans reste à charge derrière
l'ensemble des travaux et ceci
fonctionne du point de vue des masques
que nous avons masse monétaire que nous
avons évoqué juste avant par le fait que
nous intervenons sur du bâti et que donc
du coup nous pouvons ne pas fonctionner
avec de la subvention mais avec un prêt
un prêt qui du coup s'inscrit via une
garantie hypothèque hypothécaire égale
au montant des travaux qui ont été
engagés
le bouclage économique se fait
simplement par le remboursement de ce
prélat à la première mutation du bien
que ce soit sous forme de cession de
succession
ou à 30 ans ou plus tard
vous avez là le cœur du réacteur de
notre proposition donc soit
le plus simple et que vous reveniez
là-dessus avec des questions si c'est
pas c'est pas clair dans dans la
présentation
ah non je reviens en arrière là
notre dispositif nous apparaît plus
simple plus souple plus efficace plus
sans mesure de faire face aux enjeux qui
sont les nôtres parce que en fait par
cette intervention là vous pouvez vous
garantir et vous prémunir d'un certain
nombre de défauts du fonctionnement du
dispositif actuel en instaurant donc une
forme d'obligation de moyens et de
résultats pour les professionnels
et surtout l'argent qui est aujourd'hui
de fait relativement
gaspiller l'argent public à travers ma
prime rénov pourraient être réutilisé
afin de financer les ce qui est
nécessaire par ailleurs d'enclencher à
la fois donc les filières matériaux ou
la multiplication la démultiplication de
la formation des professionnels quand
c'est quand c'est nécessaire
avec un dispositif de ce type vous
pouvez également vous prémunir ce qui
est aujourd'hui une des conséquences
majeures du dispositif actuel de
l'augmentation des loyers suivant la
rénovation des logements effectués
ce dispositif là à partir au moment où
vous instaurez une obligation sur
l'ensemble des propriétaires et un
financement qui va avec laisse toute
possibilité
à l'exécutif ou législateur de choisir
par qui commencer les travaux étant
donné que toute façon effectivement
cette obligation ne va pas s'exécuter
dans les six mois qui arrive ou dans
simplement les 12 mois suivants et ça
nous on n'est pas rentré dans ces
détails là mais ça fait partie des
choses qui peuvent être qui peuvent être
faits souvent dans la discussion sur la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments est
mise en avant c'est sans doute la slide
suivante le fait que ceci est un
financement à fond perdu jusqu'où
jusqu'à combien et tout cela notre
dispositif permet de régler cette
question là elle permet de régler la
question du reste à charge
et elle permet également et je pense que
c'est pas un enjeu secondaire pour qui
c'est déjà amusé ou essayer à vouloir
rénover son bâtiment de laisser tomber
toute l'enjeu de la du montage de
dossier et du suivi des
éventuelles subventions
comme bénéfice attendu bien entendu pour
les locataires des bâtiments qui seront
rénovés c'est d'obtenir des économies de
fonctionnement et des loyers maîtrisés
tout de suite une fois la rénovation
effectuée
cette mesure donc du coup permet à la
fois de se prémunir de dérapage
financiers extrêmement important permet
donc d'avoir un bouclage économique
relativement aisé à travers ce jeu du
prêt de l'hypothèque et du remboursement
à terme c'est un dispositif qui
permettra donc de débloquer l'un des
trois blocages que vous avez vous à
faire face en tant que législateur ou en
tant qu'exécutif face à la rénovation
thermique des logements qui est la
question du financement les deux autres
que sont le la mise en place des
filières de matière ou la multiplication
de la formation des professionnels
resteront à régler mais au moins la
question du financement nous paraît
pouvoir être levée avec cette avec cette
proposition
oui alors merci à nouveau de nous
recevoir
on l'a bien compris notre projet de
proposition de loi s'inscrit dans un
triptyque qui est
on peut changer le moteur pour consommer
moins on peut rouler moins vite sa
consomme moins aussi mais on garde
toujours le trou dans le réservoir et on
perd de l'énergie pour rien et
l'isolation finalement c'est quand même
à peu près cette image et donc
pour le bâtiment ben voilà on peut
effectivement changer la chaudière c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui se fait principalement
avec ma prime rénov aujourd'hui où on
remplace par des pompes à chaleur on y
reviendra tout à l'heure sur les effets
un peu pernicieux justement de la pompe
à chaleur que l'on peut voir on peut se
mettre à 19 degrés voir à 18 degrés on
consomme moins c'est une certitude on
peut utiliser du de l'énergie bio
sourcée durable renouvelable il n'en
reste pas moins qu'on chauffe à
l'extérieur et donc l'isolation c'est ce
que nous disait tout à l'heure à la fois
l'ADEME à la fois France stratégie etc
est un préalable
je reviens sur les pompes pas cher parce
que il y a un problème qui se pose et
qui n'est pas trop envisagée qui est
directement lié à la question de
l'isolation des bâtiments c'est la
chaleur l'été et aujourd'hui on a un
nombre important de pompe à chaleur qui
sont en fait des clims réversibles qui
nous amènent et on le voit alors je sais
pas s'il y a un laser vous ici il y a un
laser je voilà si on est ici en là on
voit qu'en 2050 on a près du triplement
de la demande d'énergie pour alimenter
les pompes à chaleur et les
climatisations et donc il y a un
véritable enjeu immédiat et très rapide
à mettre en oeuvre sur l'isolation de
manière à pouvoir freiner aussi ce
mouvement qui n'est pas qu'un mouvement
de chauffage l'hiver mais également un
mouvement de refroidissement l'été qui
pose problème par ailleurs on s'aperçoit
c'est une source du rapport de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie que là
encore on s'aperçoit que dans les
centres-villes en fait
l'influence des climatiseurs et beaucoup
plus importante que dans le milieu rural
mais que donc on va avoir des problèmes
accrus dans les centres-villes donc de
plus en plus de climatisation donc de
plus en plus de consommation d'énergie
et donc de plus en plus de problèmes
voilà c'est une présentation assez
rapide que nous vous avons fait nous
avons repris
la proposition de financement qui avait
été envisagé par France stratégie dans
son rapport de 2020 et vous voyez qu'il
y a quand même une certaine complexité à
venir financer des opérateurs et en
sangliers qui eux-mêmes vont faire
travailler des artisans qui vont quand
même bénéficier des subventions de ma
prime rénov défend obligataires d'une
garantie par l'État de 75% de leur
engagement et qui seraient rémunérés sur
les économies d'énergie et donc nous
vous avons fait un petit peu avec les
mêmes graphismes le le montage que nous
proposons c'est à dire que nous avons
effectivement
des fonds qui sont levés d'un point de
vue
par l'État qui va prêter donc
l'établissement grand public va
emprunter ou bien auprès de la BEI la
Caisse des Dépôts etc va payer ou bien
directement ou bien à travers le
propriétaire après un contrôle des
travaux je crois que le
documentaire complément d'enquête et
extrêmement révélateur sur l'absolu
nécessité d'avoir un contrôle et une
évaluation des travaux en termes de
performance thermique et de performance
d'isolation et donc ensuite de ça et
bien une fois que les travaux sont faits
et bien on a un paiement des travaux une
exécution une validation et ensuite de
ça le remboursement soit à la mutation
session ou succession soit à 30 ans au
plus tard et en fait l'équilibre
budgétaire qui est prévu par l'article
40 de la Constitution mais également par
le traité de fonctionnement de l'Union
européenne et finalement assez simple on
a
un prêt d'argent mais qui est un prêt et
donc en fait le reste à charge quand on
dit le reste à charge disparaît non
c'est pas vrai le reste à charge est à
100% sauf qu'il est remboursé à la
succession ou à la session donc l'état
ne fait que prêter de l'argent et pour
assurer son équilibre budgétaire
obligatoire par l'article 40 de la
Constitution et bien il a en
contrepartie des hypothèques à du
concurrence du prêt donc sur un
appartement pardon sur un appartement où
on aurait des travaux d'isolation de
20000 euros et bien on a une hypothèque
de 20000 euros par rapport à un prêt de
20000 euros et on est sur un équilibre
ce qui permet essentiellement quelque
chose de très important dont on n'a pas
encore parlé c'est qu'on récupère quand
même les 5 milliards d'euros de
subventions actuelles au budget
puisque on les prend on les donne plus à
titre de subvention et donc on
s'aperçoit que finalement on va avoir on
va disposer d'un budget pour pouvoir
travailler sur la formation on a vu tout
à l'heure qu'il y aurait ces problèmes
là qu'on va l'avoir également
disponible sur le développement des
filières ou de matériaux ou d'isolation
pour finir je vous propose quatre cas
concrets parce que c'est ce qui nous
permet de savoir si un mécanisme
fonctionne donc le pire du pire c'est un
couple âgé qui est bailleur d'une
passoire thermique qu'il a peut-être
obtenu au cours d'une succession et
cette passoire thermique est les loyers
qu'il perçoit lui permettent de
compléter sa retraite c'est finalement
une retraite par capitalisation mais à
titre individuel je vous rappelle que
97% des logements du parc privé sont
détenus par des personnes physiques
seuls sont détenus par des personnes
morales et donc
pardon
oui oui on peut avoir des multiples
propriétés alors que se passe-t-il pour
ce couple âgé aujourd'hui il ne peut pas
avoir accès à auprès avance rénovation
qui est la déclinaison du prêt avance
mutation qui avait été institué par
Monsieur François Brotte en 2015 au code
de la consommation et donc ces personnes
là ben ils sont âgées imaginons et sans
vouloir vexer surtout pas moi imaginons
qu'ils aient plus de 65 ans par exemple
voilà et donc ces personnes là ont une
difficulté d'emprunt du contenu de leur
âge ils ne peuvent pas avoir accès au
Prêt avance rénovation puisque c'est une
c'est une location ils sont bailleurs et
par conséquent même si ils obtiennent
une partie de subvention de toute façon
ce qui va se passer dans le dispositif
actuel c'est que le reste achat d'une
part ils ne sont pas obligés à chaque
fois qu'un locataire veut que son
logement soit isolé on se retrouve avec
une commission de de médiation avec les
propriétaires dans notre système il va
avoir une obligation d'isoler sa
passoire thermique mais on va lui prêter
sans condition de ressources et sans
instruction de dossiers quasiment
automatiquement la totalité des du
montant des travaux et on va prendre une
hypothèque qui sera remboursé si la plus
de 65 ans on peut imaginer à la
succession ou à la session ou bien à 30
ans au plus tard mais pendant ces 30
années il y aura eu une amélioration par
contre on lui interdit d'augmenter ses
loyers puisqu'on lui a financé la
totalité et qu'il n'a pas de dégradation
de son compte de résultat personnel et
de son revenu qui lui permet de financer
sa retraite un multipropriétaire puisque
vous en parliez justement à l'instant
qui loue dépasseoir thermique je vous
donne cet exemple parce que j'ai
participé récemment à une conférence ou
des associations de locataires voulaient
engager des rapports de force avec les
propriétaires qui sont
multipropriétaires donc qui sont riches
donc qui peuvent isolés et je leur ai
fait observer que effectivement ils sont
multipropriétaires donc ils ont de
l'argent en revenus mais que les travaux
d'isolation leur coûte donc en enveloppe
beaucoup plus cher
une copropriété des résidents et des
bailleurs alors là ces missions
impossible nous avons consulté et
auditionné des syndics de copropriété
ces missions impossible ils y arrivent
pas vous pouvez faire les aides que vous
voulez les subventions il n'y arrive pas
parce que la moitié de leur propriétaire
s'en moquent et l'autre moitié dit mais
moi de toute façon ça va me coûter plus
cher le fait
d'avoir mis une obligation d'isolation
du fait que l'on finance à 100% sans
condition de ressources fait que les
propriétaires vous n'avez plus besoin de
décision d'assembler général puisque
l'obligation est légale obligation dont
je précise qu'elle est à notre sens
constitutionnelle puisqu'elle répond à
l'article 2 de la Charte de
l'environnement toute personne a le
devoir de prendre par la préservation et
l'amélioration de l'environnement et
donc l'isolation fait partie du devoir
de préservation et de l'amélioration de
l'environnement et donc cette obligation
est à notre sens parfaitement
constitutionnel et ne souffrirait pas
sur un projet de loi qui serait porté
par des parlementaires une une cassation
constitutionnelle
et donc dans cette copropriété le
premier vote de l'assemblée générale va
être simplifiée puisqu'il y a en étude
sur une obligation et donc l'assemblée
générale ne va avoir à se positionner
que sur le choix du prestataire des
types de matériaux en fonction de ce qui
sera donné et donc là encore on voit
qu'on a une véritable simplification à
l'intérieur et un propriétaire occupant
d'une maison bourgeoise il se trouve que
j'en ai discuté avec quelques-uns et ils
me disent j'en ai pour 100.000 euros à
isoler chez moi je vais continuer à
payer le chauffage
et le résultat des courses c'est que
nous ne lutons pas contre le dérèglement
climatique
ni contre la dépendance énergétique par
rapport à des nations étrangères ni même
alors là pour le cas de la maison
bourgeoise la question sociale se pose
moins j'en conviens mais comme vous le
voyez on a par cette simplification et
par cette équilibre budgétaire que l'on
propose une possibilité
d'ouvrir les vannes et si on a donné
tout à l'heure le chiffre de 1000
milliards d'euros sur les 25 millions de
bâtiments c'est que effectivement même
si l'on n'imaginait un taux de
subvention de 50% qui serait extrêmement
favorable et bien il reste quand même
500 milliards à faire débourser aux
propriétaires et je ne vois pas à quel
titre pour conclure je vous dirais que
il nous semble
que ni un budget de 5 milliards ni un
budget de 12 milliards comme il a été
discuté à l'Assemblée nationale n'est à
la hauteur des enjeux mais que le point
bloquant est peut-être est cela l'apport
que nous avons le point bloquant c'est
le déséquilibre budgétaire tout le monde
le sait tout le monde sait que on n'a
pas l'argent pour payer tout ce qu'il y
a à payer ce que nous proposons c'est
que ce ne soit pas les propriétaires ce
ne soit pas la collectivité qui paye
mais les bâtiments eux-mêmes
merci Madame Monsieur de cette exposée
très très claire je vais laisser la
parole à notre rapporteur
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
pour cette cette explication en détail
chez et puis le travail réalisé sur
cette proposition de cette proposition
de loi qui effectivement est sur un
sujet qui nous a justement nous poussé à
demander cette cette commission
d'enquête je dirais en partant des mêmes
des mêmes
constats que vous avez pu que vous avez
pu faire c'est à dire à la fois de se
dire qu'on a des politiques publiques on
a des ambitions et c'est ce qu'on a vu
depuis les différentes auditions qu'on a
pu avoir
des ambitions qui étaient à chaque fois
très fortes
mais au bout du compte des résultats
même quand il y a de l'argent public et
souvent il y en a enfin toujours
demander plus mais il y a eu de l'argent
public il y a de l'argent public qui est
qui est mis à disposition et des
résultats qui sont loin d'être à la
hauteur en tout cas quand on les
projette et quel que soit gérer les
études comprendre soit à Cours des
comptes ou autres
on voit bien qu'il nous faudra beaucoup
beaucoup d'années pour arriver à faire
en sorte que à la fois il y ait plus de
passe word thermique mais en tout cas
qu'on soit sur des bâtiments qui
consomment le moins le moins possible
intéressant aussi justement de faire la
part des choses parce que c'est vrai que
sur les différentes auditions qu'on a pu
avoir sur
l'idée quelque part que il suffirait de
changer la chaudière enfin en gros il
suffirait de changer le moyen de
chauffage
et du coup si on passe sur de
l'électrique bah de fait on diminue le
l'impact de rejet de CO2 c'est vrai que
ça pourrait paraître simple en fait on
se dit hop on change l'ensemble des
moyens de chauffage et on a gagné et on
a on a réussi c'est c'est enlever tout
un aspect sur à la fois le confort la
santé le coût quand même énergétique
parce que cette énergie électrique il
faut que toute façon quand même quand
même la produire et donc c'est pour ça
que je trouve ça intéressant de prendre
ça dans la dans la globalité et sur
l'intérêt d'avoir des isolations
performantes et donc la question de
savoir c'est comment comment on peut y
arriver
par rapport à votre proposition moi
j'avais plusieurs plusieurs questions
vous en avez répondu à la fin sur un
certain un certain nombre c'est vrai que
je trouve intéressant et dans les paris
les auditions qu'on a pu avoir c'est
qu'on voit bien qu'il y a on a besoin de
simplicité et que ça soit très simple
pour les personnes qui veulent entrer
dans cette de ce processus d'isolation
de leur bâtiments à la fois de
l'accompagnement et puis forcément
l'aspect financier parce que ce reste à
charge zéro ou en tout cas qui peut être
décalé il est il est important moi je
veux juste déjà une première précision
alors vous l'avez dit un peu à la fin
mais ça veut dire du coup que tout le
système d'aide qui soit primaire ou
autre Anna etc enfin tout ce qui peut
être aide publique du coup ne rentre pas
dans le dispositif ça veut dire qu'on ne
vient pas parce qu'on pourra avoir un
mixte ou ces fameux enfin le prêt qui
est fait il est en fonction des travaux
moins les aides et moins les subventions
et ensuite te dire bah voilà c'est c'est
cette partie là qui sera du coup
hypothéqué ou remboursable au bout de au
bout de 30 ans donc enfin voilà donc ça
j'ai compris du coup c'était que c'était
que c'était du coup évacué et que ça
pouvait permettre du coup de financer
d'autres politiques publiques
et du coup ça me fait sur mes 2ème
question c'était sur l'aspect parce que
vous en parlez pas beaucoup dans le dans
le texte sur justement l'accompagnement
et l'ingénierie et c'est parce que c'est
vrai qu'une fois qu'on a réglé le
problème financier on sait quand même
que il y a toute cette partie
accompagnement quel type d'isolation
quel type de chauffage au bout du compte
vous parlez des matériaux biosourcés
comment on oriente et comment justement
on fait ce choix là et on accompagne du
coup les personnes que ça soit le
propriétaire
occupant d'une d'une maison que ça soit
sur une une copropriété donc c'est vrai
que enfin je trouve que pourrait être
sur un parce que là on a quasi un
service public de la de la rénovation en
fait et donc du coup pour être accolé
justement une partie ingénierie du coup
qui puisse qu'il puisse accompagner ça
donc je voulais savoir si du coup vous
en aviez
pareil enfin imaginez quelque chose
de la même manière vous parler des
matériaux biosourcés c'est je me pose
aussi la question donc j'ai bien vu que
du coup ça pouvait permettre
d'accompagner de booster et de mettre en
place des des filières qui peuvent qui
peuvent se mettre en place localement
mais c'est vrai que sur enfin moi la
crainte que je pourrais avoir c'est que
votre système fonctionne très bien du
coup on a forcément tout le monde veut
faire sa rénovation sa rénovation
thermique parce que bah voilà c'est
c'est très accessible c'est facile on va
vite se confronter à un problème
d'entreprise de qui ne seront pas
forcément en capacité de matériaux
disponibles de tout ça quoi enfin qui
est aussi une des questions dont on se
dans son se pose et donc voilà savoir si
vous aviez réfléchi aussi dans un
système comme ça on se dit on peut avoir
un très gros appel d'air parce que c'est
quelque chose de plutôt intéressant et
plutôt alléchant quand on y a des gens
vous pouvez y aller ça vous coûtera rien
et faites-le savoir comment justement
dans le temps on peut à la fois étaler
ça parce qu'on sait qu'on fera pas du
jour au lendemain et donc du coup
comment on
en tout cas on régule ce lien entre la
capacité des entreprises à pouvoir le
réaliser et puis
la possibilité de de le faire une
dernière question c'est la parole à mes
collègues à deux questions et bien la
question c'est que vous appuyez
vachement sur le solaire thermique
pourquoi parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
d'autres dispositifs enfin et surtout on
peut enfin moi je pense qu'il y a des
dispositifs qui sont très liés en
fonction d'une région en fonction de
filière qu'on peut avoir enfin je pense
par exemple au chauffage bois par
exemple ou réseau de chaleur qui peuvent
être en place et on peut se dire mais là
à cet endroit là c'est peut-être pas
forcément ça qui est pertinent mais
c'est peut-être autre chose pourquoi du
coup avoir cet aspect très très direct
sur le solaire thermique et sur
l'obligation quoi pour le coup
là-dessus et puis sur la dernière
question moi je me pose quand même la
question sur on va dire le propriétaire
d'une maison bourgeoise ou on regarde
une petite maison qui a pas forcément
beaucoup d'argent qui est propriétaire
mais voilà je sais pas qui a acheté sa
maison quand il avait 30 ans il sait
qu'il va falloir qu'il rembourse quand
il en aura 60
qui sera à la retraite quand on aura
[Rires]
non mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
du coup il va avoir à rembourser à un
moment où justement il aura peut-être un
petit peu moins de moins de revenus et
ça veut dire que soit dans votre
dispositif soit effectivement la maison
est vendue pour X raisons et donc là il
y a pas de souci ça s'embourse mais
sinon ça veut dire qu'il faudra qu'il
ait prévu le coup pendant ses 30 ans
effectivement sur ces économies
d'énergie etc etc mais cette question là
va quand même se poser quoi ça veut dire
qu'au bout de 30 ans il va falloir quand
même qu'ils sortent la somme qu'il a
qu'il a
qu'il a j'ai faim qui n'a pas injecté au
début
et ça peut être du coup dangereux parce
que on peut se dire que ben voilà
pendant 30 ans c'est pas forcément
facile et on le voit bien de se dire
j'ai fait des économies d'énergie et et
bon c'est qu'en plus on a plein de de
problématique qui se posent sur la
question de l'isolation est mise en
place on a un meilleur confort et
souvent on va même augmenter un petit
peu donc en fait les les décalages qu'on
peut avoir ou en tout cas le gain qu'on
peut avoir sur sur l'économie d'énergie
n'est pas forcément celle qu'on aurait
pu attendre et donc du coup au bout de
30 ans Ben de se retrouver en fait pas
forcément avec les capacités de pouvoir
de pouvoir rembourser donc voir si vous
aviez du coup réfléchi aussi à cette à
cette question là voilà merci
je vous propose de répondre donc sur
l'accompagnement et sur le contrôle des
travaux bien sûr qu'on l'a prévu c'est à
l'article 8 donc on a effectivement
prévu un contrôle
nous ne sommes pas nous-mêmes
diagnosticiens mais on pense que les
entreprises qui effectuent aujourd'hui
les DPE peuvent peut-être progresser je
reviens toujours à ce documentaire de
compléments d'enquête et qu'il y a une
absolue nécessité mais il y a une
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
que on a quand même des dispositifs
techniques qui permettent de savoir si
on a des ponts thermiques ou pas qui ne
sont pas que des calculs théoriques ça
s'appelle une caméra thermographique une
thermographie complète d'un pavillon
c'est 500 euros on s'est renseigné
auprès d'entreprises de thermographie
donc on n'a pas négocié le prix mais
voilà le un pavillon c'est environ 500
euros pour faire une thermographie et la
thermographie vous permet de savoir où
en intérieur là où vous avez encore des
prises d'air ou à l'extérieur si vous
avez des ponts thermiques etc donc il y
a un intérêt c'est que à notre sens en
tous les cas c'est comme ça qu'on a
imaginé le mécanisme le diagnostic de
contrôle qui permet d'ailleurs de
déclencher ou pas l'assurance décennales
des installateurs parce qu'on a une
double garantie en fait sur notre prêt
on a l'hypothèque mais on a aussi la
garantie des scénales qui ne peut être
activé qu'à partir du moment où la
puissance publique va exiger qu'il y ait
un contrôle effectif de l'installation
et de sa durabilité donc là et
finalement si l'on rajoute 500 euros que
nous nous proposons de financer ils
comprennent avec le prêt c'est une
enveloppe globale
et bien vous apercevez que les 500 euros
sont Epsilon par rapport aux travaux de
rénovation et donc il y a notre sens il
faut intégrer effectivement à la fois
l'accompagnement et la prescription
excentée et le contrôle a postérieur
dans l'enveloppe globale de la
rénovation parce que ça en fait partie
et là alors il y a sans doute d'autres
possibilités que le contrôle
thermographique tous les cas nous on
connaît celui-ci et a priori en tous les
cas il détecte les ponts thermiques il
peut decter détecter à terme les
malfaçons qui en général apparaissent au
bout de deux ou trois ans donc on a une
capacité à pouvoir voir les choses il
faut effectivement mettre autour de la
table non seulement les entreprises
qui avons installé mais également les
assureurs de manière à ce qu'on ait une
bonne couverture parce que c'est un prêt
public donc voilà très rapidement sur
l'article 8 afin de garantir la bonne
exécution des au niveau d'isolation il
est effectué dès la fin de la mise en
oeuvre des travaux ou dès que possible
dans les conditions techniques quand les
conditions techniques le permettent un
contrôle de l'efficacité énergétique des
travaux donc nous avons bien
prévu cette nécessité et donc voilà sur
les matériaux biosourcés on n'a pas une
raie une religion extrêmement
forgé a été sur ce sujet la seule chose
que nous disons c'est que pour être un
peu des praticiens nous sommes
nous-mêmes propriétaires donc nous avons
eu affaire un petit peu d'isolation et
on sait que par exemple la laine de
verre sans aller décrier un matériau ou
un autre à une durabilité parce qu'elle
s'affaisse qui est moindre que par
exemple de la laine de bois compresser
le deuxième point c'est que il y a et je
pense que d'autres intervenants n'ont
parlé avant nous la question du temps de
déphasage des matériaux et
aujourd'hui en tous les cas donc le
temps de déphasage si il faut que je
précise peut-être pour ceux qui ne sont
pas trop techniciens en fait
grossièrement de la laine de verre va
avoir 4 heures pour laisser pénétrer ou
la chaleur dans un sens ou dans l'autre
si vous prenez de la laine de bois non
compressé c'est 8 heures et si vous
prenez de la laine de bois compressée
c'est 14 heures
sur une même épaisseur bien évidemment
et donc on comprend bien que si on a 8
heures pendant lequel le show l'été ne
rentre pas dans la maison on n'a pas
besoin d'ouvrir la clim si on a ouvert
ses fenêtres la nuit
et si vous avez que 4 heures ça vous
fait entre 10h et 14h si vous avez 8
heures vous êtes entre 10h et 18h et là
la température rebaisse et si c'est
l'hiver et bien les 8 heures vont vous
permettre de conserver de barrer la
route au froid de l'extérieur qui vient
refroidir vos murs et donc c'est 8h ou
c'est 14h sont vraiment importantes et
donc dans
on ne sait pas si c'est du biosourcer
mais en tous les cas ceux qui est
nécessaire c'est de prendre en compte
ces éléments de temps de déphasage et
pour l'instant en tous les cas les
matériaux biosourcés que ce soit what
the cellulose que ce soit fibre de bois
fibre de chanvre etc on sont à peu près
pareil d'un point de vue résistivité
mais en temps de déphasage sont bien
supérieurs et ne s'affaisse pas comme la
laine de verre ou comme d'autres
isolants donc c'est c'est sur cette
question là et ensuite de ça sur la
disponibilité des entreprises et je
laisse la parole à mes collègues
effectivement aujourd'hui il y a un
problème de main d'oeuvre spécialisée
pour faire les travaux
la question c'est que aujourd'hui on n'a
pas les budgets pour développer les
filières de formation donc c'est plutôt
de l'offre et de la demande sur le
marché du travail alors que nous ce que
l'on propose c'est que le budget des
primes et des subventions soit
réaffectés dès la mise en place du
système de prêt hypothécaire prêt à
avance rénovation mais généralisée de
manière à ce que vous récupérez dans le
budget de l'État 5 milliards d'euros qui
font un petit peu face au taux d'intérêt
imaginons qu'on ait une enveloppe de
près de 60 milliards d'années ce qui
n'est pas
excessif par rapport aux capacités de
l'État
les 5 milliards qu'on récupère en
subvention représente quand même 8% de
taux d'intérêt donc on a de quoi à la
fois financer de la formation du
développement
de production de matériaux biosourcés
présente quand même un intérêt c'est que
ça redonne un petit peu la main dans les
territoires et je sais que vous êtes
attachés comme sénateur à ce que les
territoires
ent des activités et des activités
durables et donc effectivement
il se trouve que j'habite du côté de
Chambéry
réutiliser le bois non pas pour faire
des pellets mais pour faire de la laine
de bois redonnerait quand même quelques
clés à ce territoire par exemple il y a
pas que celui-là qui a de la forêt je
vous laisse
moi oui tu n'as quand même pas tout à
fait répondu Daniel à la question de
Monsieur sur le fait que tout cela
allait déclencher une demande très
importante alors nous pensons que là ça
sera à vous aussi de prioriser parce que
notre proposition de loi est tout à fait
modeste et elle demande évidemment être
affinée bien sûr donc il y aura
probablement à prioriser ça sera la
puissance publique de le faire moi je
voulais intervenir sur la question que
vous posiez par rapport à des personnes
qui effectivement
ferait enfin utiliserait le prêt et puis
n'aurait pas la capacité à rembourser en
fait la durée moyenne d'un bien c'est 14
ans en France donc ça veut dire quand
même qu'une énorme partie des biens
tournent et que donc globalement le prêt
serait remboursé en moyenne à 14 ans
donc nous avons mis une date de 30 ans
maximum qui peut permettre de faire face
à des cas très particuliers et s'il y a
des cas très très particulier des gens
qui feraient la rénovation à 60 ans et
qui vivrait dans la même maison jusqu'à
100 ans je pense que la loi trouvera un
moyen de régler ses cas particuliers on
voulait vous redonner ce chiffre parce
que 14 ans c'est finalement peu donc ça
veut dire que le prêt que l'on fait
globalement c'est un prêt sur 14 ans
puisqu'en fait il y a beaucoup de
sessions de bien voilà et puis sur le
solaire c'est Maxime qui répond un petit
mot général
qui je pense est très important en la
matière
quand on fait la présentation de ce
projet de loi il nous est parfois
effectivement renvoyé des cas limite
comme étant du coup de nature à
disqualifier le propos général ça me
semble pas nécessairement la bonne façon
de procéder il faut bien se rendre
compte que la situation dans laquelle on
est et que nous n'avons pas de
rénovation nous n'avons pas d'isolation
efficace actuellement sur le territoire
national à la hauteur à laquelle on
devrait être si on prend que les
rénovation que les rénovations de
passoire thermique
il y en a 4,8 millions si on respecte
l'objectif que ces données
l'exécutif c'est-à-dire 80 000 passoires
thermiques par an rénové il nous faut
plus de 60 ans si on obtient un compte
de ce que dit la Cour des comptes il
nous faut 1900 ans c'est à dire qu'il y
en a 2500 qui perdent le label password
thermique par an et si on se tient
compte du réel c'est-à-dire les 45 000
rénovations globales à supposer qu'elles
se sont toutes sur de la pasteur mix qui
n'est pas le cas de l'année 2021 ou de
l'année 2022 il faut un siècle pour
rénover les passoires thermiques donc du
coup en fait moi je veux bien qu'on
parle du risque d'emballement de la
rénovation mais aujourd'hui c'est la
platitude totale en la matière en fait
et donc du coup c'est est-ce qu'on se
donne réellement les moyens pour que ça
avance et que ce soit de nature à
effectivement changer la donne
la deuxième élément ce que je voulais
apporter c'était sur l'articulation avec
les aides existantes
là aussi enfin quiconque c'est frotté à
cette possibilité ou pas de rénover son
habitation a été confronté à une
situation particulièrement complexe donc
non rajoutons pas là où les dispositifs
actuels sont extrêmement problématiques
c'est que même s'ils ont été simplifiés
avec ma prime rénov ils sont quand même
de nature complexes très différents vous
avez accès à de multiples interlocuteurs
même s'il y a des efforts qui sont faits
et donc c'est pas pour remplacer ce
dispositif là par un nouveau qui
viendrait s'ajouter au précédent la
proposition qu'on fait c'est
effectivement un effort de substitution
et qui est effectivement compliquée pour
un exécutif ou un législateur de dire
que ce qui a été entrepris finalement
aujourd'hui ne mène pas là où il
faudrait que l'on soit et qu'il faut
peut-être repartir ne pas nécessairement
d'une feuille blanche mais effectivement
dans le dispositif complètement
différent c'est la proposition quand
vous faites faut-il parler des services
publics
si l'anton est à moi oui
clairement
vu les enjeux nous avons besoin d'un
service public de l'isolation
du bâti
mais un service public totalement
renouvelé parce que ce ne sera
effectivement efficace qu'à condition
qu'il soit en mesure d'articuler les
différents échelons de l'intervention
publique du National aux collectivités
territoriales et bien entendu signifie
une participation à tout chaque fois que
ce sera nécessaire des acteurs privés
qui sont absolument nécessaires vu la
situation actuelle dans la rénovation
des bâtiments
je vous invite sur les matériaux sourcés
à rencontrer les responsables des
différentes filières moi pour ce qui
concerne j'en connais un ou deux et en
gros par exemple aujourd'hui pour faire
de l'isolation en paille alors ça peut
faire sourire mais ça fait partie d'une
partie de la solution sur sur les
nouveaux bâtiments ça marche extrêmement
bien et en gros il y a pas de problème
de ressources
il y a une filière à construire mais on
sait construire des filières normalement
sur le solaire thermique notre
proposition dans l'article 2
c'est de s'appuyer sur le sauter
thermique lorsqu'une lorsqu'une étude va
montrer que c'est efficace lorsque c'est
rendu possible et si nous insistons
là-dessus c'est parce qu'il est à peu
aberrant de devoir chauffer du bâti
chauffer de l'eau ou climatisé des
bâtiments lorsqu'on a du soleil et que
ce soleil finalement tape sur nos
bâtiments sans qu'il ne soit jamais
transformés en ressources qui est
pourtant disponible et c'est
relativement simple de chauffer de l'eau
à 50 degrés et si bien entendu vous
pouvez discuter du rendement de cette
transformation là en fait on peut y
compris probablement
investir sur des dispositifs moins
techniques mais qui permettent de
résoudre toute une série de questions
quand même intéressante de ce point de
vue là
merci alors il nous reste peu de temps
je vais laisser la parole à une de nos
collègues à Marie-Noëlle linman
évidemment votre proposition elle est
assez séduisante elle a un côté fait de
masse etc alors faut quand même savoir
que dans notre pays il y a une crainte
historique des prix peut-être et
notamment au regard de ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis puisque la première
question qui se pose c'est quel est le
taux est ce que vous avez des taux fixes
ou des taux variables ou alors taux zéro
ici il y a un prêt hypothécaire c'est
que 30 ans plus tard ça coûtera x +
x%
donc
c'est très très important parce que si
au bout d'un moment on finit par payer
trois fois parce que les taux sont
élevés vous voyez donc et ce qui sont
variables ou fixes ce qui est
fondamental sachant qu'en France on a
choisi dans l'immobilier les taux fixe
mais ça propose ça suppose aussi la
ressource parce que pour avoir des taux
fixes il faut avoir une ressource qui
permet de garantir cette au fixe donc
notamment le
ce qu'on appelle la garantie des prêts
bon aux raisons mais aux États-Unis
aussi les prêts ils sont fondés sur du
bâti et ils ont quand même demandé des
garanties animées machin etc donc
comment vous avez envisagé le principe
de garantie parce que presque partout
dans le monde mais là on pourrait faire
exception pourquoi pas mais faut
vraiment trouver le système presque tous
les prêts hypothécaires sont adossés à
une certaine financarisation et donc à
une certaine vulnérabilité quand il y a
crises financière d'accord vous me direz
quand on fait un prêt normal immobilier
mais c'est pas tout à fait vrai
aujourd'hui parce qu'on a des systèmes
de garantie à cause de cette offices en
tout cas je trouve que dans votre exposé
il manque un peu la version
impacte des taux et impact sur le
propriétaire lui-même c'est-à-dire
combien il coûte ça lui coûtera en plus
par rapport après ou non normal bon
après évidemment la résistance
culturelle auprès hypothécaire dans
notre pays qui est aussi lié au fait de
l'héritage des Français sont très
attachés à l'héritage mais comme vous
l'indiquez vous-même il est vrai que de
moins en moins
on fait pas un bien a qui va être
l'héritage à la fin qui a déjà eu ton
over avant que l'héritage puisse se
faire en cela je trouve la proposition
mérite d'être étudiée est-ce que la
Caisse des Dépôts a été posée solliciter
les gens de la Caisse des dépôts pour
savoir ce qui pourrait penser d'un
mécanisme de cette nature parce que quoi
qu'on en dise ça va faire 1000 milliards
de de
1000 milliards de dettes enfin je veux
dire supplémentaire il va falloir bien
expliquer ça en marché financier moi ça
me traumatise pas pour être franche mais
je sens qu'il y en a d'autres qui
pourraient se traumatiser
oui alors il se trouve que professionnel
allemand j'ai eu à connaître de très
très près la crise des subprimes avec
une différence essentielle par rapport à
ce qu'on propose parlons
en valeur absolue une rénovation
thermique dans logement c'est environ en
moyenne 20.000 euros on parle de 20000
euros la crise des subprimes
une personne se retrouve à 20 000 euros
sur un bien aller disons de 200 milles
on est à 10% de la valeur la crise des
subprimes se déclenche parce qu'on prête
comme en Espagne ou comme aux États-Unis
à n'importe qui y compris des gens qui
n'ont pas d'argent et qui ne seront pas
en mesure de rembourser donc là on prend
une hypothèque mais une hypothèque a dû
concurrence c'est à dire que sur des
travaux à 20000 on prend une hypothèque
de 20.000 alors je sais que cette crise
des subprimes a beaucoup traumatisé les
marchés financiers essentiellement
d'ailleurs et quelques clients de la
Fortis Banque très probablement mais
finalement
l'enjeu par rapport à la valeur du bien
et le prêt hypothécaire par rapport à la
valeur du bien n'est pas n'est pas
significative en tous les cas on peut
pas faire de comparaison avec la crise
des subprimes sur le taux d'intérêt et
de manière très rapide je l'ai dit tout
à l'heure mais effectivement sans doute
un peu trop rapidement le fait de
récupérer 5 milliards d'euros dans le
budget puisque aujourd'hui on a 5
milliards d'euros qui sont attribués que
vous récupérez puisque vous allez avoir
votre mécanisme d'équilibre budgétaire
entre vos prêts et les garanties
hypothécaires donc ces 5 milliards
d'euros sur 60 milliards annuels partons
sur ce chiffre là qui est quand même un
chiffre important ça représente 8,33%
d'intérêt donc nous nous n'avons pas
pris de position sur le paiement des
intérêts mais finalement l'état récupère
quand même 8 33 dans son budget par
rapport à 60 000 qu'il pourrait
peut-être bonifier je pense mais voilà
vous êtes parlementaire et vraiment la
balle est dans votre camp mais en tous
les cas c'est quelque chose qui est
envisageable et d'ailleurs quand on fait
des prêts à taux zéro ou qu'on fait des
PGE
voilà d'accord donc on est bien d'accord
et là on a en tous les cas la vertu de
lutter contre le dérèglement climatique
donc je pense que vous avez là des
réponses qui font que ce mécanisme est
fonctionnel
il vient de m'enlever le mot de la
bouche en faisant une référence au PGE
je vais juste sur le risque de
financiarisation si on confie cela
uniquement aux banques privées
on a potentiellement des risques qui
vont être
sous-jacent à ce dispositif si on confie
cela à un établissement public dont les
ressources viennent de la banque
publique d'investissement de la Caisse
des dépôts et consignations de tous les
dispositifs quand vous a évoqué en fait
vous avez une capacité effectivement
assez décisive à réduire au plus bas
tout risque de financiarisation et
d'emballement financier le cas échéant
et par ailleurs les cas de défection les
cas limite que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
de celles et ceux qui ne pourraient pas
rembourser pour je ne sais quelle raison
ça on sait amortir sur la masse de
volume de financement de transaction de
cession vous aurez en fait un taux de
défaut qui sera extrêmement faible et
que vous pourrez amortir sur la
globalité du mécanisme de manière
extrêmement
faisable on l'a pas chiffré nous ne
sommes que trois simples citoyens
intéressés par la question avec aucune
ressource spécifique pour mener et vous
faire cette proposition là nous sommes
je pense nous serions heureux de
travailler avec qui que ce soit pour
rentrer dans le dur et chiffrer et aller
regarder précisément effectivement comme
tout cela comment tout cela se finance
et multiplier les cas d'études
spécifiques en fonction de la maison
bourgeoise de la copropriété et évaluer
et y compris ça par contre vous serez
dans l'obligation d'avoir ces
informations là d'effectivement faire
des hypothèses sur les taux de détection
possible et jusqu'à combien ça va
embarquer de financement public pour ça
mais sincèrement ça c'est la question
résiduelle une fois qu'on acte le
principe qu'on va là dessus et ce
travail là à Bercy et dans bien d'autres
endroits on sait le faire et globalement
c'est pas très compliqué
juste
alors juste peut-être un élément
peut-être de quantification parce que
quand on parle de milliards jongle avec
les milliards mais ça en fait beaucoup
je parlais tout à l'heure de 50
milliards de 60 milliards à l'année par
exemple Jérôme Kerviel avait placé 50
milliards d'euros en 2008 5 personnes
s'en aperçoivent ni même les contrôles
donc non mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'à l'échelle de l'État français les 60
milliards sur les marchés sont
finalement
alors nous avons cru lire ça dans la
presse effectivement madame linman et
donc voilà ce que je voulais juste
répondre à ça donc sur la CDC nous
n'avons pas comme l'a dit à l'instant
Maxime pris de contact ce que je
voudrais vous dire c'est que le format
de cette audition est franchement merci
d'avoir accepté de recevoir trois
citoyens qui interviennent dans le cadre
de l'article 6 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme puisque chaque citoyen
a le droit de prendre part à la
formation de la loi soit directement
soit au travers de ces représentants et
donc merci de nous avoir accueilli et
écouter et je pense que on est à votre
disposition individuellement ou dans un
autre cadre je ne sais pas en tous les
cas pour venir approfondir peut-être les
éléments qu'on vous a présenté de
manière rapide et générale
franchement nous avons présenté ça à des
hauts fonctionnaires à des à des
professionnels du bâtiment à un nombre
de personnes et un panel de
propriétaires en fonction de leurs
revenus etc et tous ont eu cette
première réaction madame Lindemann de
dire oui mais l'hypothèque et je vais
pas transmettre une hypothèque à mes
enfants et en fait quand il commence à
regarder le système ils disent
y compris y compris pour une personne
sur une grosse maison bourgeoise qui m'a
dit mes enfants ils auront peut-être
100000 de moins mais enfin la maison
vaut un million vous voyez et donc en
fait voilà on a une vraie possibilité de
poursuivre sur ce stress question et
puis on va vous libérer nous on va
accueillir les positions
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente
merci beaucoup pour votre présentation
et j'avais une petite question je dirais
pas général mais vraiment très
spécifique monsieur bagnez vous nous
avez montré un peu le dispositif
c'est-à-dire au moment où on rentre dans
l'osseux dispositif là quand vous disiez
somme toute ce sera voilà exactement ce
schéma là ça sera relativement simple de
rentrer dans le dispositif c'est ça
l'idée en tout cas que vous vous portez
ensuite on contrôle les travaux et
ensuite le propriétaire bénéficie donc
on lui dit ok c'est super on va
rembourser cette partie bon donc tout le
dispositif que vous avez expliqué moi
j'ai une question sur la partie contrôle
en fait en réalité c'est à dire au
moment où les travaux sont effect pouvez
imaginons que les contrôles enfin que
les travaux soient mal fait soit pour
des raisons de malfaçon soit parce que
vous avez parlé de mesures que l'on
pourrait prendre pour voir que c'est
efficace soit parce qu'on se rend compte
que finalement les travaux il y a pas de
malfaçon mais l'efficacité n'est pas au
rendez-vous que se passe-t-il et qui
paye en réalité dans ce cas de figure
parce que est-ce que c'est les assureurs
qui vont prendre en charge mais dans ce
cas là on sait bien que cela va se
traduire par des primes plus élevées par
la suite donc il y a bien quelqu'un qui
va payer une fine et pour quel résultat
pour aller où voilà ma question je vous
remercie
les malfaçons existent aujourd'hui
elles sont mal elles sont pas traitées
ok là on va élargir le dispositif
si avec ce qui est économisé on a un
développement de filière et la formation
d'agent plus le développement et vous la
prenez comme vous voulez un service
public ou pas qui se fasse réellement
l'intermédiaire en fait à chacune des
étapes que nous proposons de la
simplification à la façon dont on va
fonctionner ce dispositif là vous
réduisez le nombre d'intervenants et
vous réduisez les risques de malfaçon et
de choses qui ont pu être vu chez
complément d'enquête et par ailleurs sur
le lot en fait sur le la massification
vous aurez toujours en lot de malfaçon
une partie mais cette partie là sera
résiduelle et du point de vue
macroéconomique ou du point de vue de
l'isolation prise globalement ça
invalide absolument pas le dispositif ça
ça restera à gérer mais comme
aujourd'hui
ça l'est sur sur des isolations qui se
portent simplement sur très très peu
d'habitants donc du coup en fait ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est qu'à limite
ne peuvent pas venir
parce qu'ils sont ils existent
aujourd'hui dans le dispositif actuel
dire que le dispositif que nous
proposons ne pourra pas fonctionner
c'est ça que je
veux dire donner comme réponse très très
rapidement sur ce sujet là nous avons
bien dit que les artisans les
entreprises qui effectuent les travaux
sont soumises à garantir des scénales
donc vous avez une assurance garantie
décennale que se passe-t-il aujourd'hui
c'est que cette garantie décennale n'est
pas
mise en jeu pour une seule raison c'est
qu'en fait ce sont les propriétaires qui
ont ordonné les travaux qui se
retrouvent face à cette question de la
malfaçon et qui sont incapables
eux-mêmes de le faire nous nous ce que
nous suggérons c'est qu'il y ait un
contrôle effectif par un organe
extérieur qui lui va donc mettre
directement en jeu la garantie décennale
et les assureurs c'est pour ça que je
vous disais tout à l'heure il faut je
crois mettre autour de la table les
assureurs sur cette question
si vous voulez bien je voulais redire
quelque chose qui peut être à échapper
c'est qu'effectivement ce que nous
proposons c'est un changement radical de
perspective et c'est pourquoi notre
proposition sans doute peut être conçue
enfin perçu comme surprenantes parce que
on sort complètement du logiciel
habituel de la subvention et on sait
bien que il y a beaucoup de propositions
qui ont été faites pour améliorer alors
on rajoute une petite case pour les très
très modestes ou alors une autre case
etc et en fait nous nous pensons et on
sait bien que c'est ça qui est compliqué
qu'il faut vraiment changer de
perspective abandonner ce qui est
toujours difficile ce que l'on avait
l'habitude de faire la subvention pour
un système différent donc on sait bien
qu'il y a un frein presque intellectuel
parce qu'on n'a pas fonctionné comme ça
pendant des années qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont beaucoup travaillé et on le
sait bien sur la réorganisation de ma
prime rénov il y a énormément de gens
qui travaillent nous on ne dit pas
qu'ils ont mal fait mais on pense que il
y a effectivement un é concret dans le
nombre de réhabilitations qui ne sont
pas faits aujourd'hui et qu'il y a une
urgence donc on a bien conscience avec
notre proposition de vouloir changer
complètement la règle du jeu et pour
terminer parce que je pense qu'on va pas
avoir le temps de répondre à toutes les
questions que vous nous aviez envoyé
mais on vous laissera nos réponses parce
que c'est important vous nous donniez
quand même à la fin une question
importante qui était sur le la solution
alternative de France stratégique avec
une prise totale en charge une prise en
charge totale pardon des frais sans sans
reste à charge pour les propriétaires
mais les travaux étaient entrepris dans
la proposition par un opérateur
ensemblier et qui se rembourse sur les
économies d'énergie
voilà partager entre le propriétaire ou
le locataire et voilà nous avons regardé
ça de très près nous l'avons étudié nous
partageons évidemment les objectifs qui
sont la massification des travaux et la
volonté de lever les freins aux
investissements en en revanche il nous
semble tout de même qu'il y a d'énormes
problèmes dans cette proposition d'abord
parce que les investisseurs vont
regarder la rentabilité et vont choisir
d'abord les choses les investissements
les plus rentables évidemment ils
attendent un retour non négligeable un 5
à 7 % c'est dans les chiffres donnés ça
reste sur le principe quand même d'une
subvention d'État même s'il y a la
clause de retour à meilleure fortune
dont chacun sait que quand elle est mise
en place elle est rarement utilisée donc
il y aura de toute façon des subventions
d'État donc un budget perdu entre
guillemets pour l'État cela reste aussi
avec un les prêts seraient garantis par
l'État donc il nous semble si vous
voulez que la puissance publique avec
cette proposition de France de France
stratégique donne finalement une sorte
de marché entre guillemets très qui peut
être très intéressant pour des gens mais
pas forcément dans l'objectif d'une
économie de finance publique et de donc
voilà nous ça nous paraît quand même
très dangereux parce qu'en plus on pense
qu'il y a un risque inflationniste et
que le montage est très complexe si le
montage qui est passé très rapidement il
y a quand même beaucoup de complexité
là-dedans et qui dit complexité dit
lourdeur et probablement effet de niche
et voilà ce qu'on voulait dire au moins
pour cette question mais nous avons été
la dernière stratégie
on vous laissera les réponses à toutes
les questions qui avaient été posées
avec grand plaisir et merci voilà merci
d'être à nous nous présenter cette
proposition de loi dont j'espère qu'elle
pourra à votre cheminée